And that's how I do it.
That's how I do my "night look" for going out for dinner...
...'cause dinner would be nice every now and then.
Ugh, not again.
No, you know what?
It would be nice just to go out to dinner.
Maybe you could pretend like you like having me around.
No, that's okay, you can just keep texting...
How did you get my phone?
Who is this?
What are you doing on my phone?
Tina?
"Oh, I miss you, too."
Why are you missing Tina at 10 PM at night time?
That's a bit weird.
So, following on from my "What I Eat in a Day" video,...
...I thought I would focus on dinners...
...and tonight's dinner was a homemade vegan pesto pasta.
But tonight, mine was kind of cold because I made it for dinner...
...but somebody didn't get home 'til 9:30 even though he finished work at five...
I was in a meeting.
...and no one at work knew where he was 'cause I called.
It was an outside meeting!
You reek of perfume!